hallo herzlich willkommen in meine torte
ich bin heute nicht alleine das neben
mir ist meine beste freundin nadja hallo
und ich hab euch ja bereits in meinem
frage antwort video gesagt dass ich euch
mal meine freundin vorstellen werde
die stand der bisher nur hinter der
kamera leider hübsch sehr und ich möchte
einfach ein ausblick geben was jetzt
zwei machen werden und zwar haben wir
uns beide topf geld dann verworfen und
haben die antwort bekommen dürfen dort
antrete und bisschen weise schon
ziemlich aufgeregt dabei also wenn wir
nicht ganz genau welchen tag wird
rankommen das ist ja immer je nachdem
wer rausfliegt und wer drin bleibt und
weiter macht und so weiter ihr recht
kurz also topfgeldjäger ist eine
kochshow eine koch- und wisst schon beim
zdf um 15.05 das läuft jeden tag
moderator ist ein sympathisches steffen
henssler und der juror frank rosin und
drehte einfach zwei teams an immer zwei
gegen zwei
und man kann darf ja und wir uns gedacht
wir bewerben uns einfach mal
wir können das so toll kochen zusammen
machen sie auch so
eigentlich koche ich und was hat er ist
nur ja oder films der das spiel mit
samira genau und auf jeden fall wird es
wahrscheinlich also schon so zu 100
prozent in der pfingstwoche sein ich
habe in dem staat vingst wer reden habe
im schulferien und ich denke dass wir
danach pfingstmontag ab dem dienstag
vielleicht sogar schon antreten können
dagegen je nachdem welche teams
weiterkommen wäre draußen ist und so
weiter und wege wollte um euch da schon
mal einen ausblick geben imster
unbedingt die daumen drücke
brauchen eure unterstützung wir hoffen
dass ihr uns da ganz fest die daumen
drückt und auch die einzig zdf
einschaltet mittag weil viel zeit haben
ja auch nicht mehr ich meine kamera ein
paar tage lernen bis dahin ja wer uns
jetzt auch schon unsere schützen selber
gemacht die wir euch gleich noch zeigen
die hole ich mache ja ansonsten geben
wir natürlich alle
wir geben unser bestes deswegen zusammen
noch bislang gas geben können wir machen
das eigentlich mehr aus spaß weil es uns
einfach darum geht dass wir zwei mädels
die uns einfach super verstehen und wir
wollen jetzt mal ausprobieren wie das
funktioniert wenn dann noch ein paar
kochtöpfe zwischen stehen
ja natürlich alles selber gemacht
aber wie ich hier sehr ihn die begnadete
künstlerin mit unserem eigens kreierten
entwurf unser team logo ein lern und
deswegen fand ich das auch so witzig
lebt hat er eine gefragt ob ich mal ins
and innovation und deswegen hat das so
machen müssen weil ich eben wusste dass
wir dort uns beworben haben und jetzt
aufgenommen rooney erstmals auf jeden
fall schon ziemlich und ich lerne erst
ich denke wir können noch mal ein video
vorverträgen wenn wir genau wissen mit
rankommen fliegen und so und dann hoffen
wir dass wir uns die daumen drücken
wir halten euch auf dem laufenden ja
okay dann bis bald